foreign
s an illegal gold trade worth an
estimated 700 million US dollars a year
is flourishing
black markets
operated by shadowy financiers agents
and buyers who would use any means to
keep their business going
foreign
green
it's green it is green find out how the
illegal gold changes hands and follow
its Trail
to its final destination in the
Philippines
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just east of Manila by the coast of the
Pacific Ocean is the town of parakale
also known as gold town
[Music]
um
foreign
to a highly profitable gold mining and
processing industry and many are trying
to cash in illegally
foreign
foreign
Jeremy is a minor in an illegal gold
mine it is all that he has ever known
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
six days a week Jeremy makes this
30-minute journey to panganiba
[Music]
foreign
foreign
hidden under the cover of a mangrove
swamp an illegal gold mining site is in
operation
sites Supply gold for the black market
trade
miners like Jeremy are known as players
they work at these mines without any of
the necessary permits
here the players practice compressor
mining the most dangerous form of gold
mining in the world it is also illegal
in the Philippines
in compressor mining miners have to work
underwater for long hours to get to the
gold very deep underground
they breathe through a narrow rubber
tube that is connected to a compressor
sir dug close to a river so they fill up
with water as soon as miners dig a meter
in
foreign
despite the dangers the miners only have
the most basic equipment to work with
somebody
foreign
foreign
it is almost pitch black and it is cold
outside
foreign
Jeremy is only able to feel his way
around with his hands
[Music]
he digs for rocks and puts them into a
bag
which is then dragged up the shaft with
the Rope by his friend on the surface
the rocks are inspected and the ones
with gold are kept aside
their income fluctuates from day to day
is
foreign
[Music]
of an elaborate illegal Network
they answer to the people operating
above them the financiers
forgotten
um
the financiers work behind the scenes
pulling the strings
they are the bosses behind the
operations who are willing to break the
law to keep their business going
hey
[Music]
in camarines Norte in the Philippines
people have been working at these
illegal gold mines for decades
behind the scenes it is the financiers
who fund these shadowy operations they
are responsible for assembling the crew
and deciding on the mining location
we tracked down a financier
in a small town neighboring paracale
[Music]
madagas is
for an investment of about 1 000 US
dollars to set up an illegal mine
the financiers can expect to double
their investment or more if they strike
gold
despite operating illegally the
financiers do not worry about being shut
down by the authorities some have been
paid to turn a blind eye
shots
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hidden behind a small bike Workshop we
find an illegal Rock Milling operation
[Music]
financiers bring their rocks to places
like these to separate the gold from the
rocks
[Music]
foreign
Mercury is an extremely toxic metal and
direct contact with Mercury can lead to
toxic poisoning
foreign
but the workers here seem to
underestimate the dangers
process is equally dangerous workers
heat up the mixture to separate the raw
gold from the Mercury
safety precautions workers here risk
respiratory failure all for as little as
five US dollars a day
at 2.5
grams
[Music]
10 grams
for some the cost of extracting this
small amount of gold only surfaces years
later
and it is a huge cost
[Music]
Jerry has been working in illegal gold
mines in parakale for the past 20 years
but in the past three months he hasn't
been able
to enabled universe
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Escape
no
no
there is alone
of course
it is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gusto
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
while the miners deal with the impact on
their health
agents who act as middlemen between
financiers and buyers are profiting
is
50 to 60 pesos per gram
um
uh
foreign
[Music]
can be sold
the gold is refined by trained Chemists
in illegal processing sites
1.2 grams
and
what you know
the raw gold needs to be refined to
remove impurities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
that's okay
I'll check the gold
points
it's done it's finished
it's almost 24K gold
who in parakale is buying the illegally
mine gold
in parakale in the Philippines illegal
gold mining has gone on for decades
involving miners who risk their lives
for as little as four US dollars a day
and financiers and agents who rake in
much bigger profits
[Music]
for trading in illegally mined gold
um
we follow the agent with hidden cameras
to see where he sells his goal
[Music]
[Applause]
s
computer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
make little more than four US dollars a
day the agents can make more than 10
times that amount in a single
transaction
nine thousand pesos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with so many cashing in the illegal gold
mining industry has left scars on the
land
thank you
[Music]
my location
[Music]
environmental activist archon prayra
grew up in Para colony
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
extracting good the question is
foreign
should be the main Discerning factor for
whatever
for the lgus Gina Lopez is an
environmentalist and the former
Secretary of the Department of
environment and natural resources
Philippine Clean Water Act she has long
been a vocal opponent against mining in
the Philippines accusing the industry of
destroying the environment so it's more
functional and it's more answerable I'm
going to work if you allow the
destruction of the environment in one
area you you kill the possibilities in
other areas because the way the
ecosystem works it's like a domino
effect
you know and then forget about the
farmers and fishermen just the people
who want the gold they're just going to
be the ones to make the money and that
gold is not there forever so once they
finish all the gold reserves what's
gonna happen what's going to happen to
the Future you kill the lamb
so I feel the best use of Philippine
resources is to use it in a way that it
can be forever used you don't kill it
for now and then never mind what happens
in the future and and and and I will say
the blame of this small-scale mining
this gold is the government
one they're not monitoring well and it's
not enough to say no if people are poor
and you're telling them they can't do
this you have to give them an
alternative you can say why don't you do
this and you have to help them all the
way up to marketing until they make
money
whose duty is it to make sure that
things happen well
government whose beauty is it to make
sure that I
llegal things don't happen government
whose duty is it to make sure that our
poor don't suffer government so if
government makes choices to benefit the
rich what will the poor do
[Music]
many illegal miners continue putting
their lives and health at risk for the
sake of their families
[Music]
balloon
yes
Apollo doesn't want his son to go
through the same ordeals
foreign
believes that the Persistence of illegal
mining is knocked down to Poverty alone
she feels that the problem lies at the
very top where some in the government
have a vested interest in mining
activities
operate the mines hello
my God no I mean there are people that
are represented in Congress and whatever
that that themselves have mining
interests
in the Philippines mining funds
political campaigns so every time you
find a political campaign that
particular politician is indebted to you
all the patients consistently make
decisions that cater to business
interests even if it meets the violation
of Filipino rights it's really really
sad
[Music]
while agents are small time dealers who
operate mostly in shops around town the
sellers operate in the larger market
buying and selling in larger quantities
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to Manila
foreign
[Music]
but most of the gold end up
approximately 350 kilometers away
in binondo
manila's Chinatown
binondo is well known for its many
legitimate gold Traders
but according to sources from parakale
some of the traders in binondo are also
big time buyers of illegally mined gold
[Music]
by law local gold producers in the
Philippines must sell their gold to the
central bank
but many prefer to do their business at
this black market
we set up an undercover operation to
talk to a buyer at the black market
you guys ready we already
is it filming now it's rolling yes
[Music]
we spot a man standing around
suspiciously
posing as interested gold sellers we
approach him
[Music]
he turns out to be a gold agent
s
Black Market dealers here routinely buy
refined Gold without asking for any
documentation to verify its source and
illegal practice in the Philippines
foreign
the agent offers to introduce us to his
boss a big time gold buyer
[Music]
[Music]
his boss is waiting in a quiet corner
behind a row of legitimate jewelry shops
[Music]
24.
99
foreign
thank you
the buyer becomes suspicious and ends
the deal abruptly
we decide to leave before our cover is
blown
[Applause]
it is estimated that in 2012 90 of the
gold from small-scale mining in the
Philippines was traded on the black
market and sold overseas
it's the
it's green it it is green because you
don't need the gold you don't need the
gold but our people need water our
people need food our people need air and
it is wrong for the government to allow
greed to put at risk the lives of our
people it is wrong it's against our
constitutional right
for some the demand for gold has
devastated their lives forever
[Music]
[Music]
November 21
2012.
income
in
[Music]
um
happened
in
this afternoon the mines at barangay
palanas collapsed killing Julie's
husband and three other miners who were
working Underground
[Music]
um
foreign
cash in exchange for her silence
is
foreign
with no other means to support her
family
Julie accepted the money
it was not an easy decision
is
[Music]
the authorities attempted to track down
the financier of the mine but he was
never found and nobody was held
accountable for the accident
until today
Julie is still haunted by the tragedy is
[Music]
hello
[Music]
tragedy prompted a major investigation
into the dangers of compressor mining
it resulted in the Philippine Senate
passing a nationwide ban on small-scale
gold mining
foreign
illegal gold mining continues
[Music]
since 2012 it has claimed 10 more lives
despite laws Banning small-scale mining
it is likely to continue if enforcement
is lacks and when there are simply no
alternatives
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]